hi all um i'm amanda from the japanese
foundation for cancer research
i'm currently the group leader for the
cansonial antigen vaccine development
group
today i would like to speak with you
regarding the
the ngx liquid biopsy experience that i
have for the past few months
on the gene axis system
so with the advancement of molecular
targeted drug it has been a routine to
perform
molecular tumor profiling using
the tumor biopsy tuna tumor is still
remain the standard for molecular
profiling of tumor
however there are some limitations as
there are times
that the tumor tissue in is inaccessible
and not
enough material sometimes to be obtained
for molecular profiling in addition
this tumor tissue obtaining this tumor
tissue is pretty invasive
as we are using a very long needle to
poke through the flesh
and obtain a piece of the tumor as well
as we all know that the tumor is highly
heterogeneous
needle biopsy only collect a piece of
these tumors as you can
as you can see on these slides where
there are three different clones in
colors
in green blue and purple and
by using needle biopsy we were able to
only see the green and blue clones
and left the purple color undetected
that will be
subsequently regressed after treatment
lastly since it is very invasive it is
very difficult to repeat and it is
not practical to be used as monitoring
to to monitor the disease progression
for the past few years the term of
liquid biopsy attracted much
attention owing to its minimally
invasiveness
as a potential complementary approach
towards the
conventional biopsy with the advancement
of highly sensitive
ngs it is now possible to detect genetic
alterations such as
mutations copy number variation and
fusion in our body
biofuels such as the blood plasma
the self the cerebral spinal fluid
saliva
urine and etc since liquid biopsy is
circulating in the body
it helps to provide a a pretty
comprehensive tumor profiles
like what you see in this example all
the different
clones might be able to detect it by
using liquid biopsy
because also because of the minimally
invasiveness liquid biopsy could be used
for sampling
repeatedly for monitoring the disease
status
after some of the intervention medical
intervention
that would carry out such as surgery or
or treatment
so among the different
types of liquid biopsies my lab focus on
circulating tumor dna
so the this ct dna is shaped from the
tumor cells into the circulatory system
it is either viable it is either wire
viable
tumor cells or wire the secretion from
phagocytes
cause and government of the tumor cells
or when the tumor cells in fact go
through necrosis and apoptosis
a very important point here is the
half-life of
this circulating tumor dna within the
body
only leave about 30 minutes to 2 hours
in the bloodstream
so it gave us a very good real-time
assessment of the tumor conditions
and this circulating tumor city dna is
the size it's ranged from 150 to 200
base pair
as you can see at the bottom
figure cancer detection or
ct dna can be used for cancer detection
or screening
it can use for molecular profiling or
prognostication
it can be used to detect minimal
residual disease after
some surgical intervention could be used
for monitoring response
of some of the treatment and eventually
it could be also
monitored the coronal evolution as well
so this is the routine and jazz workflow
in my lab
we firstly extracted the cell free to
the nucleic acid
and we use oncoming cell free essay
and please hd cell free ac for library
construction
and templating in the ion chef system
and sequence using ios 5 prime and
data analysis was performed using eon
reporter
we besides the commercially available
oncoming pan-can
bank cancer cell free aca we also design
two
panels to meet our research purposes as
listed here to address their screening
cell free ac as well as gfci actionable
mutation cell free aca
i would like to emphasize that the
following panels
are in fact integrated with molecular
barcode that reduce
sequencing error and could help in
detecting alterations
at the limit of detection up to 0.1
percent
even though ngs technology nowadays is
highly sensitive there are still
limitation in molecular profiling
so first of all it is very laborious
so if we send out a sample to some of
the companies or laboratories
it takes up 10 days to one month and
it definitely affecting the turnaround
time
and and in order to get back the report
the second is related to its cost
performance
most of the companies or even
laboratories we try to wait until
the maximum samples to be run in a chip
so there are some of the time lost
during this
waiting time as well
so these limitations has addressed by
the gen xs
integrated sequences as it is fully
automated from the nucleic acid all the
way to the report
within a day so that we could know the
results
pretty time pretty timely
and additionally the system was designed
that
the ngs could be performed even that is
one sample
without wasting any extra consumables
all the consumables are comes in
much in strips so all we need to know
use is only the amount according to the
number of samples that we
run so in addition to the
oncoming the gene genexis system i would
like to also introduce the oncoming
precision
assay that are introduced by the
thermofisher
so this essay cover 50 genes that could
detect the mutation
copy number gain or loss and also the
fusion drivers
as far as i understand that this panel
is
a newly designed panel with a new
technology to detect fusions not just in
the tumor tissue as well as in the cell
free to the nucleus
as well so the genes out of the 50 are
on labels 19 genes is in guideline and
47 genes are already in use in global
clinical trials
bear in mind that this panel also
integrated with molecular barcode that
helps to reduce the sequencing error
this is particularly very important
because
this is also to detect
the very minor mutations in the liquid
biopsy
so the if there is a sequencing error or
false positive then
it will be very difficult for us to
detect the mutations
pretty confidently so
do the presentations um contents
today i would like to evaluate the
performance of the genexis
sequencer with the opa panel
firstly using the control tissue and
surface of the nucleic acid control
samples
i will be covering the input data
varying calling
both the mutations and fusions and
secondly i would like to also
present the results using the cell free
tna samples
um from the non-small colon cancer for
this part
part of the presentation i will go into
a bit more details regarding the
sequencing parameters what will be the
molecular depth
and the evaluation of the amplification
efficiency of
the panel and i would like to also show
cover a little bit more on the detection
rate and the concordance with the tumor
tissues
first on the first part
so we receive two ffp
control samples those this control
samples runs in duplicates and runs in
different days
and the input of the dna is 10 nanogram
rna also in 10 nanogram and the overall
overall depth is about seven more than
7000
x i think this is pretty reasonable for
molecular profiling
and the first ffp sample which is the
the
figure on the left-hand side the first
ffpe control is a five percent control
that contained 74 mutations
the mutations were detected as you can
see in the blue
um daughter blood
the box so the mutations
frequency were detected in the range
from three to six percent
only two mutations were detected in um
the high frequency
but the result between the two
duplicates are very similar indicating
these are not false positive
and the second ffp controls are
contained mutations with different
mutation frequency that range from 3
to 15 so the the table here sorry is a
little bit small
is the duplicate results of these 15
mutations that runs in different days
they are pretty similar and they are in
very good concordance
next we would like to evaluate how
efficient is the sequencer and the panel
in detecting fusions
by using the tissue rna control so
the first control that we included is
the ffp
rna control number one there are from
sarah k and track cell uh
android gene fusions so we could see
that all the antrac genes
fusions were detected with a particular
breakpoint
in the in the brackets so which is good
the second rna controls we also included
the
five percent serra k fusion control that
contain different types of
clinically important fusions so most of
the fusions were detected
by ranging from four percent to seven
point eight percent so these are also
very similar to the five percent fusions
that us
that are listed in this table
as we are also running um the
past samples of cell-free dna as well as
the tissue samples by using oncoming pen
cancer
cell free ac so this time we would like
to compare the results
of the concordance in between the
oncoming pan cancer cell free essay and
also the opa panel using eight
colorectal cancer
tissues for opa we evaluate using
genexis and with the oncoming pen cancer
cell free they say the angiotensin is
performed by using ion
gene studio s5 prime system we could see
that the mutation call from the eight
tissues are highly concordants that can
that in fact achieve
with the r square more than um 0.98
percent indicating the validity of the
mutations
that caused by this both of these
systems
as you can see that the concordance are
pretty high in between the
the opa panel as well as the oncoming
pan cancel panel
and lastly which is also of my interest
we also evaluated the system using the
cell free dna controls
with the gene axis and opa panels so we
try three
horizon diagnostic cell free dna
controls with different mutation leave
frequency and one healthy plasma
according to the thumb officials the
panel is confidence
in detecting mutations up to limit of
detection of
0.2 percent and in 0.1
um cell-free dna control as expected
we detected the mutations that near to
0.2 percent
the system were able to detect all the
mutations
in 1 and 5 and none of these mutations
were detected in
healthy plasma and we also tried another
cell free dna control by spiking in the
oncospan
um control into the healthy plasma
we were able to detect mutation as
listed here
so the mutation frequency range from
0.11
to 4.02
and next i would like to move to the
second part of my
presentations that is to evaluate the
performance of g nexus integrated
sequencer
with the opa panel using car-free dna
samples
from the non-small cell lung cancer so
as i mentioned earlier i will introduce
some of the sequencing parameters
that include the molecular depth and so
on
so we using the clinical research
samples that
are 48 cell free tna from the advanced
muscle lung cancer
and recruited from the cancer institute
hospital of japanese foundation for
cancer research
all of these for the example 19 of them
are newly diagnosed with
egfl positive 26 are in fact
they show progression disease after the
first generation of egfr
and also raw targeted therapy and
three of them are in fact monitoring
samples there are no detectable pd after
the egfr targeted therapy
so this this graph
summarize the input and the molecular
coverage of 48 samples
as you could see on here
the input cell free dna that we use is
range from 13 to 20 nanogram
the total turnaround time that we use
for these 48 samples is
12 working days which is four samples
per
day so the median overall rates
for this um this this um for the example
is about 8.6 million rates 8.7 million
weeks
the median overall depth is about thirty
thousand more than thirty thousand
x so the median molecular coverage is
about
a thousand six hundred x and the median
molecular coverage for twenty nanogram
inputs
is a thousand seven hundred and seventy
eight
in another way which means that we can
get one thousand seven hundred and
seven one thousand seven hundred
of molecular depths
with the 20 nanogram inputs
so we could see that there is um a range
of this is the the blue bars is
in the in input of the cell free dna
and the orange is the molecular depth so
they
we can see that it doesn't have any
correlations in the
molecular coverage with the input
of the cell free tna
so in my lab we also evaluate whether
there are amplification preferences
within the panel
so we utilize what we call as relative
molecular coverage in which
we try to divide the molecular coverage
of each amplicons with the media
molecular coverage
of that particular samples
so to put it in the pretty simple term
is
if the relative molecular coverage is
1 which means that that particular
epicon has the same coverage
with the media molecular coverage so
this particular
diagram include the summary for 48
samples
and this graph in fact is divided by
the genes each of the genes that cover
in the opa panel
so we could see that the number of
amplicon cover
in each of the gene for example um
three amplicons for akt1 and
six amplicons for tp53 so there are two
points that we could observe from this
graph
the first one is besides the ar genes
which is
the androgel receptor genes this gene is
located of chromosome x
and they are gender variables
the other standard deviation of others
amplicons are in fact
not big so not very big indicating that
there are consistency of the
amplifications of the panel and the
genexis system
the second observation that we could see
from this graph is
we observe among these 250 amplicons
they are there are 14 of that
have the 0.5 relative molecular
less than 0.5 relative molecular
coverage
indicating that molecular depth of these
amplicons is half
than the media molecular coverage why is
this
important because the low molecular
coverage
in fact will directly affect the limit
of detections
that is the false negative for liquid
biopsy
and next i would like to move into the
the
um the results for detecting the
variance
so among the newly diagnosed
patients samples 14 out of the 19 which
is 74 percent
of plasma suffrage dna detected to carry
um which is this part to carry egfr
sensitizing mutations they are included
um the la5ar exo90 deletion rg
um the substitution of g719
and t790m is already known to be
well known as a resistance mutation for
egfr tkis
as we can see that if the sensitizing
mutations were detected
in the liquid biopsy it is in fact
complete concordance
with the tissues diagnosis this is a
very
important information among the samples
that collected from
the patients who experienced the
progression disease
12 out of the 40 were detected to carry
the same sensitizing mutations they are
in the tissue diagnosis but
as far as we know that we also
detected seven um six out of the 14
samples were detected to carry a t 790m
so as expected within the monitoring
egfr tki samples we do not see any
mutations
which is indicating that the patients or
these samples
might is still responding to the to the
treatment
next i would like to move to the second
important information for the egfr tki
so in addition to the egfr mutations
that
we summarized just now
more than five percent of the samples
also carry other mutations on tp53
better cartooning genes
p3ca b rav keras and co2
rb2 genes so as you can see
in these particular reports the
concurrent tpv3 mutations predict poor
outcome of egfr tki treatment in chinese
patients
with the advanced non-small cell lung
cancer so
having the mutation detected in liquid
biopsy
of tp53 mutations is important that
these patients require
more monitoring and it will help in
the prognosis of the of of these
patients
additionally these pie charts also
summarize
all the mutations that are related to
resistance mechanism of
egfr tkis as we know that sixty percent
is in fact the t 790m that we
discussed just now there are also other
mutations that are indicated
um to be related to
egfr tki resistance and we in our liquid
biopsy projects we
results we also identified the p3ca
and b ralph mutation as well as other
additional
mutations that might be normal
resistance
mechanisms that could be identified by
this opa panel
so next i would like to move to
the out tki
results so these are already these
samples were collected from patients who
experienced pd after using the
inhibitor or roth inhibitor so
seven out of the ten inhibitors
were detected to carry at least one
mutations and two of them also detected
with the roth one inhibitors also
detected to carry
mutations i would like to emphasize only
these three
samples that are detected to carry
out mutations detector mutation the
detector mutations here
are known to be the out inhibitor
resistance mutation
as we can see in this report these
mutations
include um the i1171s
the g1269a
and g1202r those are all
known resistance mutations that could
also pick up by liquid biopsy using the
opa panel
so in conclusion gene axis integrator
sequencer is
a fully automated and highly accurate
address system with a
one just one day turnaround time
hospital mutations copy number
um gains of loss fusions rivals were
detected in control tissues and cell
free tna using the
oncoming precision ac in our
samples collected from non-small
cellular cancer sensitizing
gfr mutation we detected approximately
74 percent
um and egfr mutation positive plasma
sample were in complete concordance with
the tissue samples
in all of the samples we also identified
some known resistance mutations
were detected by using this opa panel
so i would like to show my
acknowledgement um
so these are my team members and i would
like to particularly um
thanks to the funding agency
and all of these
project are supported by the ar hospital
projects
and as well as i thank the patients and
their family who participate in all
these studies
thank you so much for your attention
you